first of all abby good to see you you
look so good thank you for coming out
here i know there's worse places to be
than by the beach so thank you yes i get
some tranquility here do you feel at
peace i do when i see the ocean i yeah
you needed your conch shell here do you
feel at home
yes i like the shells i like the
starfish that's right you know all that
i love it well listen you know this
month marks four years since your cancer
battle left you unable to walk and yeah
i still see you everywhere wait a minute
my cancer battle didn't leave me in the
chair okay it was the failure of six
doctors in 10 days that put me in this
chair four years ago this month four
years ago yes and yet you're still as
active as ever though i mean how do you
feel today right now yeah i feel great
let's go to lunch yeah okay i'm gonna
take you up on that well you know i can
go to lunch and go to dinner yeah i can
shop you can go to concerts i saw you at
topic show yes yes if it's handicap
accessible i can go so you know i can
shop and i can eat and there are two
things that i'm really good at
really good at shopping and eating so
but it gets me into trouble you know i
just spend money and i sit in a chair
and eat so looking back on these last
four years how would you say that has
changed you the whole experience
immensely i say
please and thank you
at least 100 times a day
and to strangers when you're in a store
and i get caught between the clothing
racks uh getting poked in the eye by the
edges of hangers just dropping things on
the floor dropping my car keys in the
parking lot you know all of those things
become
a huge problem they're problematic it's
an effort you know for me to bend over
and try to pick something off off the
floor i can
to bend over and pick something up off
the floor i can do it but i have to
lower my chair i have to put my feet
down i have to lift up the armrest i
have to bend over and try to grab it and
sometimes you need help but so you have
this new sense of gratitude it sounds
like i do and i have such a respect for
people that are handicapped i had no
idea none before i was in a chair and
you see me out we bumped into each other
at the concert and like i said i go to
dinner i shop i do this i do that you're
living your life i am but no one sees
what goes on behind closed doors
absolutely and it's tough it's tough
your whole life changed getting out of
bed
putting your clothes on
uh your
whole bathrooming skills
all of those things are so difficult
brushing your teeth and then you forget
and you just go to you know spit in the
sink and
it's all over you because you can't get
close enough to the sink it's just
everything changes is that crazy how
when those types of tragedies happen to
us our life perspective changes right
you start realizing the things you maybe
took for granted in the past i do i do
and here in santa monica the city of
santa monica the sidewalks are so bad
the tree roots all that jazz it's it's
horrendous trying to wheel around uh but
i need to be able to wheel right i don't
want to have to get in my car and drive
everywhere you know live in the suburbs
that's why i live over here by the beach
and you're not the only one either
there's plenty of people who are
probably needing that same assistance
right they do
unfortunately here
in this city
because i'm in a wheelchair yeah i'm
looked at as homeless
it's crazy that is crazy especially if i
have shopping bags on my lap then
especially i'm definitely homeless
especially when you're living in a
penthouse in santa monica yeah well yes
yes
people don't see that they just see you
out on the street and
you know the children recognize me
immediately and they want a picture and
they run up and hug me and i'm afraid
i'm gonna wheel over their feet but
adults people the strangers just your
scum have there been any positive
takeaways from what you've been through
in the last four years besides that new
life perspective
no no no it's
being thankful and grateful for the
people in my life the people that stood
by me through thick and thin through all
of this i love them dearly and for the
strangers there's an old irish proverb
when you need a favor ask a stranger
people have been wonderful to me
however
i'm a little bitter
i'm a little angry why is that at the
doctors that said
go home and take it easy you'll be fine
i just finished shooting a documentary
about what i went through what happened
in my
federal camp my staycation
and uh
what happened
over the next two weeks when i was
released and i was in a halfway house
trying to get medical care while you're
under the government's jurisdiction in a
halfway house was insane
having to go to the doctors that were
within a mile radius instead of where i
needed to be or where i wanted to go and
that was
detrimental obviously so knowing what
you've been through and knowing you're
at this place where you want to share
your story what do you hope people take
away from it when they watch that
documentary i want them to know really
why
i went away
exactly why and what happened because
there's so many different rumors and
fragments of statements out there that
people think it was about tax and this
and that and it wasn't and i also want
predominantly women to know their bodies
and when something is wrong
keep fighting keep asking the questions
keep going to another doctor because
i did that i went to hollywood
presbyterian i was in hollywood that's
where the ambulance took me and they
thought i wanted drugs i don't even like
to take the medicine you know like just
off the streets yes yes just wandering
in an ambulance right right ambulance
yeah then you know with 24 hours of
being discharged i was back in again
with the same symptoms
how do you have a woman who is
white tan tan really tan beautiful tan
always white as it goes
sweat dripping
babbling gibberish
screaming in pain
and go home and take it easy right
there's something wrong
and
uh one of the other doctors that i went
to his office was above a hospital
why wouldn't you take me downstairs walk
me there by the hand or call downstairs
and say hey i'm sending someone in that
needs an mri we need to find out what's
going on with this woman or run a ct
scan do her blood work again let's get
to the bottom of this no here's some
protein shakes so you this documentary
is addressing all of that yes i'm naming
names you're naming names okay i was
gonna say is this like are you exposing
the people you feel who are responsible
for this well i want them to know what
happened to me
maybe they didn't watch the news that
was on every channel right that maybe
they didn't watch entertainment tonight
and see what was going on with me that i
was in a wheelchair
i shouldn't be in this chair if any one
of those six doctors
would have caught this they would have
started chemo
immediately before the cancer had choked
my spinal cord when the burkitt lymphoma
attached itself and started to choke
that's when the damage was done
and that happened over a 24-hour period
i became paralyzed from the neck down
just 24 hours yes that happened that was
on friday the 13th i went in
and by the 17th i was paralyzed from the
neck down wow yeah i want to switch
gears a little bit and focus on some
positive yeah because you do have an
exclusive reveal for us miss abby lee
miller has a man i hear i do you do you
should have maybe caught me a week ago
because he he was better he kind of kind
of
yeah he kind of drowned himself a little
bit listen men are perfect they are not
perfect but i know that i'm not perfect
either exactly none of that sorry so i
get it i just i don't know
it's hard
it's really really hard and especially
in this town
you know i think if i was back in
pittsburgh i don't know there's a lot of
doctors there's a lot of medical people
there's a lot of attorneys there's a lot
of you know just nice guys you know a
lot of quality here i don't know about
the quality i know and you know also
back east there's a lot of like blue
collar guys like my dad worked for the
railroad every day for 43 years but
you're here you've got a good pension i
know you're here so i know knowing that
a good man is hard to come by i'm too
guys is this an actor yes it is i'm
dying to know how y'all met at a party
an oscar party look at you yes see
you're you still got it yes you're going
to oscar parties and picking up men yeah
in a tuxedo you know you have to own
your own talks please tell me the rules
okay you have to own your own tuxedo
okay you have to be able to go to the
theater and
theater etiquette okay you want to see a
broadway show and dress up for it yeah
of course and the belt
you know the belt matches the watch
strap watches the shoes yeah that's key
okay so so far he's checking these boxes
off well
tuxedo theater yes be able to drive a
truck drive a stick
drive a sports car
drive anything okay and maybe build some
props like for the dance
recitals and you know you want a
handyman yes i'd like a handyman but but
refined a refined handyman okay do you
feel like you are training him on a
couple of these prerequisites i feel
like he's a little too
dry say this
he's a little
you know you can't teach an old dog
matrix
you know i like them young okay so what
attracted you to him then this is gonna
sound so bad
say it he's a good plus one you know
what that actually
is one of my prerequisites that's on my
checklist i think that's really
important especially someone as busy as
you as famous as you you need a good
plus one yes yes and he owns his own tux
yeah yeah okay are you happy i'm happy
there's a couple
there might be another two guys from
other two guys so we'll see what's your
secret i'm over here taking notes
because i have i got zero zero in the
basket well i think one thing is they
would have children that
watched the show okay and so there was
like a connection they would hear my
voice in their house all the time you
know that's one the other thing is just
being out here and you know being away
yes absolutely so you're not on the apps
you're not allowed these people
no but what do you think about only fans
are you on only fans yet abby no okay
i'm not you're not but i have a few
friends that are making some good money
[Music]
you